I'm joined now from Tokyo by Julian
Richards a Former Intelligence Analyst
at gchq and currently director of the
center of security and intelligence
studies at the University of Buckingham
thanks so much for for joining me
um Julian so I I guess my first question
is why there is now a growing fear
around tick tock's safety is it because
of growing distrusts for China the
country uh which the parent company of
tick tock comes from or is it growing
understanding of perhaps the scale of
data that that this app versus other
tech apps might be collecting from from
users
it's actually a combination of the two
um I mean The Tick Tock has grown
enormously the
um it's it's one of the most popular
apps uh on the planet at the moment and
the amount of data it's collecting on
users around the globe is becoming quite
extraordinary so if if any government
wanted to use the data source for
nefarious purposes it will be a perfect
platform to do that now that doesn't
necessarily mean that that the Chinese
are doing that but concerns have been
mounting that this is
um this is possible I'm reaching a whole
new level
but but I I get that but I guess my
other way of putting it is if Google was
Chinese would we be taking the the same
action or rather is there a fear that uh
tiktok is gathering almost in a hacking
way more data than they claim to be
claim to be collecting are they also
reading potentially someone's emails at
the same time as opposed to just knowing
which type of videos you like and
dislike
well it's possible the problem with any
Chinese company is that there's not
really any such thing as a completely
private company in China and that's just
a a institutional fact
um it's also the case that the Chinese
government has the right legally to
extract data from any Chinese company
that it wishes to do in a way that isn't
the case with Western companies so the
Chinese government has the capability to
tap into the the data that Tick Tock has
again it doesn't necessarily mean that
it is but it just means that that
capability is there and given the the
scale and breadth of the the app now
that's become a real fear and and if the
government now has sufficient evidence
on this to to ban it as we expect later
today from government phones or phones
of government ministers why would they
not ban it from phones of the whole
population
well this is where um the nature of the
data becomes important and so there's
two things really one is that
um government users if they're using
Tick-Tock uh more likely to be using it
for sensitive governmental information
so they might either deliberately or
inadvertently reveal um details of
military capabilities or
um or more importantly would
um reveal the location of individual
Personnel in the government as they're
moving around the world now private
users of course the same fears don't
necessarily exist because
social media is social media and if if
somebody is not necessarily a sensitive
individual or likely to be a target of a
hostile foreign power then there's less
concern over that the second problem of
course is that um we we generally take
these moves very reluctantly because
we're supposed to allow freedom of
speech in our country
um it's we're not a country that
normally where the government normally
tells people that they can't do this and
they can't do that so to to extend this
Beyond governmental users would be a
very big and probably impossible step
what is Free Speech we're meant to allow
free enterprise and and welcome
competition this app is clearly done
incredibly well in in recent years to
what extent is there an aspect of
protectionism uh with all this because
it is not owned by a western uh company
well of course that's what the Chinese
are saying that they're saying this is a
a nakedly political act it's it's an act
of
um
capitalism on steroids it's reducing
competition I I think it's more
complicated than that I mean that the
particular we have to be clear about the
particular connections that the Chinese
government has into companies of this
nature and it would be totally different
if this was in any other country
um but the the Chinese government is
expanding its capability it's expanding
its um its connections into Data
companies and just the sheer scale of
some of these companies now and the
amount of data that they're collecting
um has has caused this to be a real
concern
and and just finally if you consider in
Broad terms Julian the way in which
we've become uh more adversarial less
trusting of China and whether it's data
or other issues that they might collect
is is that a fair conclusion in your
part or is is it moving too fast against
them
no I I do have many of us have serious
concerns there's a real tussle going on
in Western governments particularly the
UK and the us but others also between
the China Hawks who want us to take a
increasingly tough approach on China
across the board and the pragmatists who
who want us to feel that we're going too
far and too fast and this is going to
cause serious problems for the future
and at the end of the day China is you
can't ignore China you have you have to
engage with it you have to do business
with it
um so this this is a massive step and
it's it's one that does take us into
dangerous territory longer term I think
Julian Richards thanks so much for
joining me